first time in more than half a century
congress will hold a public hearing on
one of history's great mysteries ufos
for the first time in over 50 years a
subcommittee in the house of
representatives is holding an open
congressional hearing on uaps
the term unidentified aerial phenomena
has replaced the unidentified flying
object or ufo the public now has a
chance to hear directly from experts and
leaders in the intelligence community on
one of history's greatest mysteries
pentagon officials have been
tight-lipped on the details but here's
what we do know there have been nearly
150 reports of unidentified aerial
phenomena since 2004. only one of which
was explained in a report that led the
pentagon to form a special program meant
to streamline data surrounding the
unexplained occurrences intelligence
committee chairman adam schiff says he
hopes to break the cycle of excessive
secrecy and speculation with truth and
transparency the hearing will be
followed by a closed classified hearing
on that pentagon program that was
recently established